i  actually made maybe he's playing it  really nicely going  queen d6 once  making him sit there and shake his head  for five minutes and then okay he  actually went nice so 26 yeah  how do you play queen d6 in one second  that's so undisciplined  i don't even think about it no he can't  smell the blood in the water dude be a  [ __ ] shark  yeah he carries  this is the reason why you are the world  champion for quite some years and not  no i don't know one small detail  you are the shark no money no matter how  much you eat up other people you still  want to eat one more yeah but it's  well  let's say  five i mean objectively you're equal or  slightly worse like how much are you  really risking practically speaking  i wouldn't say too much  yeah